yo-yoing back and forth between two safe
squares there's just no way to generate
any other play i mean because
look at white's pieces there aren't too
many of them so that's
the problem number one and the second
one is okay the white rook has got no
lines to attack so
unfortunately is forced absolutely to
take the repetition
and uh will we see him play on he knows
to draw on the loss same thing okay he
plays on
he's on buddy okay so level of rooney
and says
yes you took my knight but i'm still a
rookup um
you can do nothing else other than go
for this drawing mechanism again
um so it still exists white can just
move the knight again give a check
um you have to check on the right square
we should mention otherwise black's
queen can actually block the check from
white's queen in the middle of the board
so that's why the knight goes there but
position repeats again yeah we're about
to see a draw
third time we see that position aronia
wins today's match
he does the armenian what an impressive
achievement here in the first match in
the final levonorone and he won one game
and that was enough he is the winner of
the first